THE WHITE HOUSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
LET’S BRING IN SOMEONE ELSE WHO
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THE WHITE
HOUSE, KAYLEIGH MCENANY, CO-HOST
OF "OUT NUMBERED" AND FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY,
KAYLEIGH GOOD MORNING, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING, PETE.
PETE: GREAT JOB ON "OUT NUMBERED
" BY THE WAY.
SO WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO JEN
PSAKI SPENDING MORE TIME AT THE
PODIUM ATTEMPTING MASSAGE THE
WORD CRISIS AND WHAT IT’S
REALLY ABOUT THAN ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING IT?
>> YEAH, IT’S BREATH TAKING.
I WENT AND WATCHED THE FIRST 25
MINUTES OF THE BRIEFING THIS
MORNING, AND SHE USED THE
WORD "CRISIS" BUT NOT IN
RELATION TO THE BORDER.
SHE SAID WE HAVE A CLIMATE
CRISIS ON OUR HANDS SO WE’VE GOT
A CLIMATE CRISIS, WE DON’T HAVE
A BORDER CRISIS, WHEN BY THE WAY
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THESE
CHILDREN ON THE BORDER IS
ATROCIOUS, THE CONDITIONS, THE
FACILITIES, IT WAS A HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION ACCORDING TO
KAMALA HARRIS DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION, BUT NOW IT’S JUST
THEY TURNED A COMPLETE BLIND EYE
TO THESE CHILDREN IT IS AN UN
MITIGATED CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER FUELED BY A
CRISIS IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
AINSLEY: WE SAW IT LAST NIGHT ON
HANNITY’S SHOW HE INTERVIEWED
THE PRESIDENT FIRST ON DASHCAM
RAIL ENTITLEMENT INTERVIEW SINCE
HE LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE.
I FELT THE STRONGEST PART,
KAYLEIGH, OF THAT INTERVIEW WAS
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER, BECAUSE HE SAID ALL
BID EN HAD TO DO WAS NOTHING.
LEAVE IT THE WAY IT WAS, LISTEN
TO THIS.
>> PEOPLE ARE COMING IN BY THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS, THEY’RE
WALKING IN.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS LEAVE IT
ALONE.
IF HE LEFT IT ALONE WE WERE
SETTING RECORD POSITIVE NUMBERS
AND PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO COME IN
LEGALLY AND YOU KNOW, THE OTHER
THING THAT PEOPLE DON’T TALK
ABOUT, HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
DRUGS.
THAT’S DOUBLE, TRIPLED AND
QUADRUPLED COMING IN BECAUSE
THAT’S POURING IN RIGHT NOW.
DRUGS ARE POURING IN.
WE HAD IT SO TIGHT, WE WERE
DOING SO WELL.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS LEAVE IT
ALONE.
AINSLEY: THEN HE WENT ON TO SAY
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY SO
WE HAD TO GO THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM TO GET IT AND THEN BIDEN
COMES IN DAY ONE AND ENDS ALL OF
THIS.
>> THAT’S RIGHT, YEAH,
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT IT RIGHT.
YOU CAN’T ARGUE WITH RESULTS.
YOU CAN’T ARGUE WITH THE 78%
DECREASE IN ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS.
YOU CAN’T ARGUE WITH THAT.
HE USED COMMON SENSE AS HE
MENTIONED IN THE INTERVIEW
YESTERDAY.
THE WALL WORKED.
I WENT WITH HIM.
I SAW THE WALL FIRSTHAND.
IT WORKED.
THESE AGREEMENTS WITH GOLDEN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES AND MEXICO,
THEY WORKED AND BIDEN DESTROYED
AND DISHANDLED THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
BUT YOU SEE THESE LITTLE TASKS
ALONG THE WAY THAT I THINK EVEN
HE RECOGNIZES THOSE POLICIES
WORK BECAUSE MAYORKAS REPORTEDLY
TOLD PEOPLE WITHIN DHS WE MIGHT
CLOSE SOME OF THE GAPS IN THE
WALL, THEY WENT BACK TO
MEXICO AND GOT TROOPS ON THE
BORDER SO YOU SEE THESE
LITTLE ADMISSIONS THAT THEY ARE
REALIZING AND IN FACT WHAT HE
DID WAS COMMON SENSE.
BRIAN:  I MEAN, LOOK, THE
PRESIDENT BIDEN GETS DISSED
ALL THE TIME, LIKE
BY THE PRESIDENT OF ECUADOR,
THEY GOT ASKED COULD YOU SEE
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S ENVOY, NO
BECAUSE YOU WOULDN’T SEE ME WHEN
I CAME TO WASHINGTON, SO REALLY?
THE PRESIDENT SAYS IT’S NOT MY
PROBLEM, BECAUSE THEY HAVE PRIDE
TOO, AND THEY WERE DISRESPECTED
EARLY ON BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> YEAH, THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT
OF MEXICO CALLING HIM THE
MIGRANT PRESIDENT AND
PLACING THE BLAME FOR HIS
ILLEGAL FLOW DIRECTLY AT HIS
FEET AND THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES YOU HAVE ONE PRESIDENT
THERE SAYING HEY, SMUGGLERS ARE
USING YOUR LANGUAGE, JOE BIDEN,
TO GET PEOPLE TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY, SO WHEN YOU HAVE
TWO WORLD LEADERS AND YOU
MENTION ECUADOR SO THREE,
CALLING YOU OUT, SOMETHING IS
GOING WRONG HERE.
BUT HE’S TOO PRIDEFUL I THINK TO
EVER BACK-PEDAL, ALTHOUGH THEY
DID FRIDAY EVEN THOUGH JEN PSAKI
WON’T ADMIT IT.
PETE: KAYLEIGH REAL QUICK, AS
WELL, YOU MENTIONED LANGUAGE,
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS THEY WANT A MORE HUMANE
POLICY, SO I.C.E. AND THE BORDER
PATROL ARE NOW SAYING YOU CAN’T
USE, THEY PUT OUT A MANDATE.
YOU CAN NOT USE ILLEGAL ALIENS.
YOU CAN NOT SAY ALIEN ANYMORE,
IT’S ALL UNDOCUMENTED, MIGRANT,
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN --
AINSLEY: NON-CITIZEN.
PETE: WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN
YOU’RE CHANGING THE OFFICIAL
WORD AND DOES IT MAKE IT MORE
HUMANE?
>> NO IT DOESN’T.
THEY’RE FOCUSED ON A WORD.
WHEN THERE ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE
BEING PLACED WITH PARENTS THAT
MAY NOT EVEN BE THEIR ACTUAL
PARENTS BECAUSE APPARENTLY
THEY’VE LIGHTENED UP THE VETTING
PROCEDURES WITH PLACING THESE UN
ACCOMPANIED MINORS, THEY ARE
TRAFFICKED HUMAN TRAFFICKED,
ABUSED ON THE JOURNEY HERE AND
THEY’RE FOCUSED ON A WORD?
IT’S WHY PEOPLE LIKE SENIOR
DEMOCRAT LAWMAKER HENRY HENRY
CUELLAR A DEMOCRAT HAS SAID I’LL
STICK WITH THE ORIGINAL TERM
WHICH BY THE WAY, IS IN THE
STATUTE UNTIL YOU CHANGE THE
STATUTE I’M GOING TO USE THE
WORD, BECAUSE HENRY CREW IS
A DEMOCRAT WHO UNDERSTANDS THE
REALITY OF WHAT’S GOING ON,
BECAUSE HE’S THERE, AND IN THE
BORDER AREA WHERE EVEN
KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN WILL
NOT TAKE A MOMENT TO EVEN VISIT.
AINSLEY: WELL KAYLEIGH THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING ON WITH US THE
PRESIDENT WAS ALSO ASKED
ABOUT THE J & J AND HE SAID THAT
IS SO STUPID WHAT THEY DID.
ALL RIGHT, WE’LL LOOK FOR YOU ON
"OUTNUMBERED" CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN.
BRIAN:  AND WITH PETE GIVING YOU
THAT COMPLIMENT HE’S GOING TO
WANT TO BE ASKED TO COME ON THE
SHOW THAT’S WHY HE WAS DOING
IT.
BRIAN:  THAT’LL MAKE BRIAN VERY